foreign
days of the year the corridor secret
santa we've been going for years it's a
tradition you know how secret Santa's
work right everyone gets a random name
and you have to get a gift for that
person and they're gonna try to guess
who gave it to them all these gifts have
to be top shelf gifts I don't want to
see gift cards I don't want to see asset
packs well no trash nope no trash
garbage
is this garbage there's literally screws
in here why is this two years in a row
two years wait it's not even a hot dog
I know what this is get this freaking
trash can
look there might be a gift card there
might be an asset pack but we we hope
that it will be done creatively and with
joy
[Applause]
so many of you
uh Sam where are you at
snowy winter Forest yeah Thomas Kinkade
uh hyper detailed uh yeah
what
[Applause]
it's not a this is a tiny banjo
it's not a tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
very reasonable though very reasonable a
banjo man you are
oh dang
Clint
[Music]
goals
this guy there's like a bunch of
something yeah yeah yeah it's got the
whole it's a whole set yeah it's like
accessories this is my first banjo
[Music]
uh I'm here in the movie uh the entire
uncut movie To Kill a Mockingbird which
is in the public domain so you can just
let it play behind me the whole time
neck back massager
and my broken bones you know what I'm
just gonna enjoy this nice heartfelt
moment between me and Jake yes yes do
you know you know how you get everyone
knives well anytime somebody breaks
their collarbone I get them a neck back
massager for Christmas
[Music]
and for when I can't be here uh hello I
am in a cozy Canadian Christmas right
now all right somebody got me whiskey
Moss burn single malt scotch I'll have
to see if this is a low land or a
Highland Scotch somebody get me a book
notch in a book yeah I love you
the Marxist reader
[Laughter]
I guess I'll have to take my time with
this one
Daniel
reveal yourself Jake I know we're both
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I appreciate that it's still legal in
Texas to shoot somebody if they're
carrying a Marxist oh great okay
just be careful with that I am in a
cyberpunk dojo attended by gorillas in
suits octane render award-winning
[Laughter]
it's a blanket I got a blanket
oh
foreign
are you kidding me
who has access to my Instagram account
[Music]
[Applause]
jpeg
oh wow
oh oh okay okay I don't know why you'd
think I would use something like this
no this is gonna be great for all my
blunt smoking
seriously whoever got this you're classy
as pet it's like a potion bottle
there's a little little ashtray so you
can set your fat balloon I mean what am
I gonna say you know you would have
gotten me an ashtray set Nico I'm very
flattered but no I'm not that classy
Ram
no okay
[Applause]
thank you yeah I hope you like it man I
was gonna put Pocky in there wouldn't I
take one bite I'll save the rest oh
great that's great swim gym Maybe
all right
dude I'm in cecilton right now
do not Shake
okay from Santa
[Music]
I think there's a letter in there was
there a letter I messed up wait a minute
it's a picture of a flask there's a
photo of somebody in the reflection of
The Flash
did you give me this
okay and then based off the wrists I'm
gonna say Ren last
uh I heard this a month ago but it's
custom it's the Carmichael press and it
says always ready so I put some Scotch
with that dude thank you
that looks like bren's hand that looks
like Red's head I mean okay
[Laughter]
I'm in a lone cabin on the top of a
Mountaintop looking out the big glass
window to the snowy landscape oh I guess
I got a three-parter
all right
oh a cocktail smoker kit cocktail smoker
kit
[Music]
whiskey stones
Japanese whiskey to put it all in Nico
really
uh I guess reveal yourself I am
Spartacus
there's two of my favorites yeah there's
two glasses there so you want a drink uh
yeah that's why I got it all right man
I'm ready oh man environment I'm in a
blizzard like a raging blizzard
tape I have to say it is this trash dude
freaking duct taped it on the front
[Music]
oh climbing here dude
Clint oh
is Peter yeah
dude thank you so much man you're
welcome Hey you missed a gift oh wait
let me sit back down oh
he's painted me a picture
I'm sitting in Jamie Oliver's real home
kitchen
oh it's got voltage information that's a
good sign portable mini fridge yeah this
is in fact a mini a mini refrigerator
dude that's super sick who here knows
that I love Refrigeration Solutions Mika
nope
[Music]
it was me
thank you hey man I know you like energy
drinks and I never wanted you to be
without a cold one or a hot one because
this keeps things warm too oh that's
okay really cool man I know hot Red Bull
is like really good
I'm in Gatorland bro come on what a big
old Chopper behind my head wow
Should I shake it
this is what I'm gonna be at my desk I'm
just gonna be popping these things it's
like a it's like a little fidget toy
this is the most insane thing I've ever
seen Nico really
I'm surprised too that I guess
it's Jordan Allen it's not
enough
sneaky I don't know if you notice I
fully appreciate but it's Among Us
[Applause]
oh yeah get your pops
um I am in Scranton Pennsylvania
I am in the office Dwight's desk
preferably
oh Dusty greens grow your own nutrition
oh that's so cool see Mike it said vegan
on it so I thought of you oh
[Applause]
yeah I know you like uh you like grown
plants I know you like eating healthy so
I thought I'd give you a little
something to eat both well it's great to
be here with you at this screening of RR
[Music]
thank you very much
who done it
blue Destiny unit one exam
s
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
I am hovering over the Vegas Strip right
now making it easy for you Dean
oh you guys know that I wear my hat
oh and a beautiful bottle of Kentucky
bourbon oh
oh I stationed gift card I actually
don't own a PlayStation
[Laughter]
who might potentially sell me his
PlayStation 4. so he's got a friend with
a place
I feel like I've talked to rent about
PlayStation before and maybe he thought
I had Ren first guess we're in well I
know you have an Xbox I've talked to you
about PlayStation as well Christian damn
it
[Applause]
you didn't mention what system okay I
appreciate it it's the thought that
counts man I make good use of the
whiskey yeah
I am on this very green screen but
it's a JPEG and it's banding
aggressively and you Dean keep me on to
it please one click key is this just
meat
I think before I open it Nico
no way
we'll wait all right what do we got oh
reading material they know I'm a scholar
hard-boiled Wonderland and the end of
the world alright in this hyper
connected
is this also hard-boiled that's the
question
okay this is the best Christmas
look at that chocolate chip are you
kidding
I'm on the left field this thing and go
with the man who has it back to me Clint
is this you is this you yes sir yes I
knew it
loving you man and this is love yo
they're a little flat all right but yo
those will raise your heart rate for
sure that's what I'm counting on man
hopefully
I am enjoying a nice binary sunset on
Tatooine oh yeah that's nice to me
double gift oh there's a beard kit I
have facial hair oh a little bearded
coffee mug
I like it I'm gonna guess Austin now
oh yeah Merry Christmas
I'm on a blue screen
foreign
[Applause]
I had a theory and now my theory has
changed
oh I know exactly who it is now so this
is a a van again but it's like a model
you get to build of it yeah
yeah for those of you who don't know I
have this van very full circle that
Daniel got me this thank you so much
foreign
look at that ready look at that
spot on he even has my son right there
thank you so much man that's really
really fun happy holidays yeah oh I'm so
pumped on this uh we're in a fractal
Universe oh wow
right on okay I I think I have a pretty
good idea better yeah
but I am a huge fan of Fallout I've
played like everyone huge Fallout 2 fan
this is super cool right now I am on I'm
inside of Jordan Allen's desktop right
now
I'm a little I'm a little scared right
now
curious who's writing that is oh
wow this is really nice I'm gonna guess
wait Christian
well I also know you got a brand new
gaming computer
I actually need it in your mouth so it's
perfect okay so we're actually looking
at me five seconds in the future so if
this is this is what's about to happen
hell yeah
okay holy hundred dollar gift card to
the Alamo Drafthouse and it also says
download Adam visual illustrator dreams
is that an asset pack
did you get all three things this is
wonderful what else we got what's going
on here and it is
[Music]
42 I have one guess who this is from and
it's my boy Carmichael
we spend time together this year so I
wanted you are we going to the movies
together no but I want you with your
special someone to go to the movies no
let's go together okay let's go okay
right now oh yeah yeah oh shoot I got I
have to do this oh okay yeah and then
we'll head out I'm in front of a video
showing Jordan Allen drinking a nice ice
cold glass of milk
buddy Merry Christmas and now what we're
all here for my gift
oh yeah
yeah I love the image on it it's got
like a like a little Sombrero man and
then a big old cauldron of Bubbles and
sauce that brings me back to the
motherland
oh no
intense ass knife that fits that fits
nice
stop now who was it now which one of you
the name on the box was Christian
I haven't gotten you Knife yet then like
this is the right of passage it's like
the first default gift you know everyone
needs to have a huge ass night I mean I
know you're into like other things yeah
but if I'm really important to just get
this one off the list thank you so much
yeah
uh I am definitely in natural Hot
Springs with some snow monkeys
almost the one in the back you've got to
go all the way wait oh interesting
yes
[Music]
what have I become open up let's see
what's inside come on we're all waiting
[Applause]
that is eco-friendly right there
dude that's that's real that's actually
true
[Music]
Pro Nemo yeah what dude this is rough
[Applause]
all right all right all right nope this
is not sealed I can't tell if it's trash
or not
thank you
maybe that's part of it I'll put it here
there's a ball
[Applause]
[Music]
we made it finally geez
this is the most this is some Carmike
it's not a real guess
[Laughter]
okay tea and honey these go well
together especially in the holiday
season and this looks like a candle it's
a stone candle thing this is a great
gift this is like a candle some tea and
honey I mean dean
God dang it all right who who was it
oh
Jonah thank you this is very thoughtful
I do want you to know none of this trash
is from the street I've collected this
trash are you for real yeah I collected
this trash over the last like two weeks
and it's all from my house thank you not
growing thank you clean that out thank
you my favorite moment of the Year lots
of favorite moments obviously there's a
lot of great things happen this year son
of a dungeon awesome fun doing a
narrative storytelling is a big project
being able to be a part of son of a
dungeon season two and seeing all this
wild creativity come out of the team
being able to contribute to that in a
small way was a really big deal to me I
came here to to work on sewed and it was
such an amazing process where I got to
meet everybody and I got to learn so
much highlight of the year I'd say
releasing episode seven of son of a
dungeon season two so that way everyone
could see how Nico influenced D
then episode nine when it all came back
together for a great finale we were in
the studio and we were recording son of
a dungeon Jake just kept on rolling so
poorly four gosh dang it oh oh my mind
was that I swing again that's the three
did somebody help me please there's just
so much laughter that's going on in the
studio uh while we're shooting some of
the dungeon and those are some of my
favorite moments I mean we made freaking
punch for punch this year
that was so much fun to develop with you
guys and like make work and look like a
show I'm glad that like this still small
Studio can make something that caliber
you know I think that that everyone
brought their A-game to it so super
proud of everyone for that
to the Moon baby
I would say my favorite memory was
shared with my bat boys or Adam West
Batman video and having Matt Reeves
tweeted out having Adam West's family it
was my first like real project at
Corridor and
I was so stoked on it it was really
awesome favorite moment would probably
be when I was inserting a knife into
Adam Savage's nose and then slicing it
open and spraying blood across his face
that was very surreal and never thought
I'd be doing that but we got to do it my
other favorite moment might be the uh
the Steve the landlord reveal in our
little made-up
yeah yeah that's pretty fun I think
getting back into making the scale
videos with a scale of data as like a
month-long moment oh and
[Applause]
and hanging out with Adam Savage throw
that in there
in there favorite moment of the Year
probably getting to meet Tim Miller the
dude is super cool down to earth it was
just cool to meet like a big time
Hollywood director like that and then
obviously getting to edit his episode
I'm actually currently working on
episode two so that video is actually
coming out soon guys stay tuned for that
[Applause]
uh favorite moment of this year
obviously it was a pretty recent one
Fender and I were cranking on this
spider-verse video we were super happy
with it favorite moment would be Batgirl
not only just doing something I've never
done before like learning choreo but the
nights that we all spent together doing
something like that and then as a family
it was amazing every moment for me is uh
probably being part of getting to make
this psych and this trust has been
pretty exciting last week we shot this
Christmas render video and uh it was
just a blast sitting down with my boys
wonderful Vibes cozy all around can't
complain surprisingly one of my favorite
moments was stressful it was when we got
hacked because I know it was my fault
and it was my fault but no one here made
me feel bad about it we all came
together we problem solved we got the
channel back no pressing on so I
appreciate that it was my fault and I'm
glad we fixed it
[Applause]
my greatest memory is not one video but
all the videos I will have made by the
time the year is over 45 videos I'm
really proud of that
how can I even choose so many awesome
memories but a highlight was definitely
Wheeling around San Francisco with the
boys when we went to film with Adam
Savage and the whole like tested crew
good memories watching RR with all of
you that was my favorite moment this
year
I like to think it inspired us to rise
up against our oppressor Markiplier
enough
one day I was having kind of a rough day
I didn't really want to do the podcast
that day but we got in there and we just
were crying from laughter from some
stupid idea we were talking about I just
really enjoyed those moments because
um they're good they're fun what am I
thankful for I'm thankful for Jake's
consent because
I think I got it I here if I verify Jake
Watson I am currently speaking and that
I'd like to script to create an
overdubbed version of my voice
and well maybe I technically never did
but but the point the point is though
it's weird when you do these videos you
you create a video or a concept you also
create a story that goes with it and
sometimes those stories get a little too
real for you guys you know what I'm
saying it's because sometimes these
story lines go a little get a little out
of hand every now and then you just
quickly steal someone's voice in
perpetuity yeah
that was a really intense week but I'm
glad that we got to talk through it we
made a big big old podcast about it it
was a great experience I'll remember
that forever you have my consent Sam
in general I would just say everybody
here has been my teacher at some point
and has like taught me so much getting a
full year here has been such a treat
it's been an incredible year I'm so
fortunate to be here with so many
amazing people I love all of you guys
you guys are amazing I love you guys you
guys are wonderful
[Applause]
guys Nico you didn't say it Nico Austin
bring your knife
[Music]
it wouldn't be Christmas without this
last gift for everyone there we go oh
yeah
[Applause]
who wants a Christmas pudding
[Music]
my puddings hey everybody thank you so
much for watching we could do this
without all of you we got a lot of crazy
stuff planned for 2023 in the meantime
you know tell us what your favorite
moment from our videos this year was but
uh at least for all of us here at
Corridor thank you so much see you guys
in the new year yeah
[Applause]